[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back top the record
where we talk about whatever we want and
today we have Eric aka super ego actor
in a comedic youtuber and our friend
roastmaster I think hey that's what I
think
hi I thought it was great yeah wait did
you know Steve or us before I knew you
guys I need you guys and then I met
Steve I had Steve on our jamia made me a
maker I did meet your maker alright who
do you like better us or Steve easy call
definitely you go it's mutual it's
mutual good to know Steve I'm going to
sleep are fighting my attention here
guys are fighting right now yeah well
anyway congratulations on your twin boys
thank you yeah yeah - boy I'm in heaven
- boys I have a question about that so
like I guess from me growing up more
traditional it's you get married and
then you have kids and now there's a lot
of people that just have kids first
mm-hm getting married or like without
needing to know the security of the -
like what's the thought process behind
wait so you had long the message you're
not getting married
you just have some cabin kids itches it
was something that we didn't do like you
know traditionally what good lice and
just have a spotlight yes Jesus this guy
right my friends are like that - what a
[ __ ] Apple does mouth already
talking about you God didn't get married
no I'm not married I don't know what
Steve's talking about he is crazy
it's okay Steve day no listen I think
it's really nice that you're breaking
all the traditional things that your
real ground breaking no friends oh I'll
back you up I mean I I did that I had a
kid before yeah thought process behind
that well I mean for me it was a very
naive very dumb 17 year old thinking
that she isn't ready for a baby did he
ask you like hey you what hit me
yeah like now I just want the kid no no
not very
do you definitely I have a baby and I'm
like okay Oh without the marriage part
yeah but when I was pregnant though and
because I was like a teen mom right so I
got all these dirty looks every time I
went out and everyone's just like oh my
god I hope she'd be so pregnant and so
young and all these things so because of
that I felt the shame and every time I
went out in public I wanted to like I
was this close to going to one of those
$0.25 rings and like getting one just to
put one on the team but you didn't have
the 25 cents it didn't I was that broke
but now when you see a Teen Mom do you
go up to her and you're like good for
you comment on someone else's lives the
way people did like unintentionally I
don't know but the way like they gave me
the stairs and maybe it was me
projecting my own shame onto others that
what if they were like that's a hot
pregnant mom no I look like a baby with
the freaking basketball well maybe it's
because you're wearing a little mermaid
pajama pants maybe that's why what are
those new twin belly look like though
probably like that three months she
looks like you seven months you know
what she's actually really tiny so she's
got like you know she's really like thin
and so she's just from the back you
can't even tell it's just it has to be
one of those type of things where she
turns around she's like ha
and she's like BAM you know so she's
about we're almost about to hit like
five months yeah but boy twins it's
growing differently like normally like
there'd be like a ball I think for one
but she's kind of got more like a like
an oval look Wow
I wonder if they're like little spoon
big spoon in there or they're hugging or
like how do they save all that space I
mean they're just on top of me sure they
fight for it yeah they fight for it yeah
when we were looking at the sonogram
like they move so much sometimes it can
be like up and down like this or they
can be side to side she's like what yeah
yeah so she'll be like laying down and
then she'll have to move according to
like the baby sometimes they're on one
side she's off sides she's like oh you a
little seat yeah you all let me see like
a lot more on this side right now
already it's just like it's crazy good
names yeah we do
dude if I had twin boys I always dreamed
about this our name room Riggs and
Murtaugh what about you but now
Chippendales good - that's hella good
I'm trying to convince her for for Rick
and Morty oh you want to start them
angry off at each other or else we'll be
fighting they were at the beginning dude
came around a little mention kid named -
Bobby's pretty funny
okay a little Mexican kid named Tupac is
pretty bad word before you do have names
though yeah we do but you haven't
revealed no not really
people yeah we're pretty locked oh you
know what sucks - when you're in this
ages your friends might see your name so
you got to be [ __ ] careful I know I
had a buddy almost stole the name
because a couple people know the name
that we're gonna use for our kid did
they're like no I like that name yeah
and this [ __ ] I got in his head
so well [ __ ] I did such a good job
pitching the name dude what if it's like
John or some [ __ ] it's like you name
stealing [ __ ]
I came up lit up that's how I got my
name yeah my dad heard someone else say
Eric and they're yeah I'm like dad it's
a fake story I mean that oh okay you
almost had names are they at least can
you tell us where they're um that can be
found in the Bible okay
so I also like like names that you know
me my girl we agree that we like names
that can be said in English but also in
Spanish ah it's mine doesn't sound good
thinking how did they say your name in
Spanish so it's Eddie like my grandma
says it
arrey arrey you know like that or they
call me Eddie or sometimes just Eddie
that's humiliating I get it yeah yeah so
you gotta do the double I'm gonna fight
Steve yeah I get it now my cousin's name
is Erik but he's he lives in Mexico so I
just come in they spell over the seer
kick that's like K so you're not gonna
marry this chick well I thought Bart was
complimenting you on your
non-traditional there's so many people
doing it now so I'm like is this
interesting I think it's so cool you're
not locking it down and doing the
traditional thing and like making your
mom happy I don't even know why because
you wanted to do that uh-huh I want to
get no fur no you did it no you did it
well he did give him some credit Jesus
he doesn't be major first yeah yeah but
now cuz it was his idea
that was was it your idea uh I brought
it up yeah good your family's right huh
you like you better marry me before you
start busting nuts or what oh no no I
was just like I think we should do this
cuz then my parents are gonna be not
happy
true they're Catholics my dad didn't
care my dad's like just you have kids
first it's like I don't care if you guys
get married or not if you didn't even
care with who he was just like have kids
yeah since I was in college is like just
have kids please Wow well that's cuz you
wanted you wanted man like why don't you
impregnate your roommates yet they don't
even know that girl roommates do college
he only had girl roommates they're dudes
anyway so you guys been together almost
two years yeah a fun little ride yeah I
do plan on getting married when no
pressure you know dad I just want to
know I'll I'll be your mom in this video
when are you getting married
we're talking about possibly before the
baby's coming
Oh
so but then at the same time like I kind
of wanted a little like nicer that's
what I don't want to seem to for so mean
who are talking about it is if we're
gonna do something like small and cute
now just to just have the rings yeah
and then a big YouTube one later and
then a big YouTube one later with like
are our twin make so many villains dude
I'm excited multiple weddings yeah
sponsor - Oh long you gonna be a family
blogger now yes I'm gonna hop back on
the vlogs I've been often you should for
a minute people love family vlog you
know and then like blogging the whole
pregnancy because twin pregnancies
aren't that common
well we did we did the gender evil we
had like a party and we did like I had
like two cameras I even had like a drone
I captured like that but we missed so
I'm excited for that to come out it's
gonna be a hell of you is bro that's
crazy
but everyone already knows the gender
yeah I don't care I think I think big
spoiler that you've on down I mean
because there was a lot of people
already there with their phone so I'm
just like oh don't post it into another
video you know like it was just like she
just posted oh don't you love YouTube
parties like that I know everybody I
have to make an announcement please
don't post this [ __ ] cuz everyone was
just gotta wait to eat I'm like [ __ ]
yeah I mean whatever you know if you
guys what's the actual video you know at
the stand-up specials now the ones that
they know they're gonna film they
confiscate all the phones yeah yeah I
think that's pretty cool
what do you mean yeah phone pouches
little locket yeah and the minute you
bust out a phone they see it it's like a
sons of anarchy meeting okay yeah
they're coming to take your phone away
smashing shows yeah that you you have to
lock it there's like a lock box where
you have to play yeah wait that the last
Dave Chappelle did you guys watch this
mm-hmm
sticks and stones yeah it was like a
phone that went off specials at war yeah
because I remember like always just how
did he see that one yeah cuz they always
check for one phone at the door they
never check for two phones
somebodyís honey was calling this to
Louie CK show you a couple years ago get
triggered [ __ ] I went to a louis c.k
show whatever uh yeah and and if if you
had multiple phones they didn't know you
put one in your side yeah I had anything
- oh but what about it oh the phone
thing yeah what if you went to a
gender-reveal party and then you had to
lock up your phone oh my god imagine
hope what if prove you guys just turning
your phones
grab my you - you know I bet if Kim
Kardashian had one or it would make
sense
mm-hmm does that reveal so big right
yeah that one makes money millions of
dollars yeah a bunch of people does
anyone even read vogue who gives a [ __ ]
anymore do they good do not you know I
feel like you're the most fashionable
person here no offense to what that read
vogue dude behind the now read vogue um
I don't think so I mean like magazines
are just kind of not what they used to
be perfect that's what I thought okay
what's your point I thought I thought I
made a good reference and I did good for
you but so where did your name come from
I'm really curious words super you go
people um II go are my initials Eric Gio
cha and I thought I'd be very creative
and just said super to it um when he was
taken and so it was - so what had
super-ego yeah so then you made the ego
yeah that was some old-school YouTube
[ __ ] you're a fan maybe however
YouTube's changed a lot since we started
bro it's changed so much I know we were
like kind of there at the be like at the
beginning I remember when did you first
start posting like oh seven oh eight so
funny thing is Tim my boy Tim you guys
know had Tim you may be short mmm yes
okay oh yeah begin up Timothy delegate
guy we actually opened up my first
youtube channel and she started popping
up videos for me and and then I was like
cool let me just start off my own [ __ ]
and yeah just slowly from there it just
kind of picked up and started doing
skits and I started [ __ ] around like
like the troll oh [ __ ]
and I remember my mom and like my
stepdad were like oh don't do that [ __ ]
you're gonna get [ __ ] up on the street
yeah you know at that time yeah yeah
like mom you don't know Stan's a bunch
of nerds right now I felt like I just
felt like a lot of like a lot of people
like my community didn't like have a
laugh
topper a computer yet to be watching me
you know so I was just like well I think
I'm cool but whenever like the first
encounter I had was this guy at the mall
and this guy had like tats all over easy
oh [ __ ] and then anything that said la
on it um close the Dodgers very close
all right we're loyal that's right
that's right
precipitation on their face yes
precipitation a couple Dodd yes and
anyways I'm crossing this guy and we're
at the Cerritos mall and this guy's just
like you've what your walks past me just
like hey go oh [ __ ] and so I turn around
my heart's beating I'm just like yeah
cuz hey you do them in total video huh
okay I was like this is it I'm gonna get
my ass beat right now like in the
[ __ ] mall and then I'm like yeah you
know the teardrop looks like clipart to
me clipart
clipart it could be I mean it basically
is clipart I think that's what's so
funny about the teardrop one you haven't
seen the one with like the actual like
glistening of the teardrop I know I saw
I just mostly see the one with a little
blue get the little circle in it like
for like it's shining what are the three
dots pretty good my crazy life may need
a locker yeah why are you having kids
cuz haven't you seen you for you haven't
oh man makes you want to not have kids
at all maybe you shouldn't watch it like
really [ __ ] up I don't know I just
finished season one about dad I'm
[ __ ] good kids are a [ __ ] headache
it's crazy all those kids in are like
teenagers and like you just see all the
crazy [ __ ] that they do like drugs and
like sex [ __ ] don't near what's that
you're about to have twins bro yeah boys
are better than twin girls man I believe
that's all the twin girls out there I'm
just saying you guys that time we're
better than two girls do you think that
don't worry about the guys getting
pregnant oh I wasn't thinking that but
girlfriends are like the most st. girls
ever I mean they party no I'm not like
saying like I'm just saying in terms of
what I would worry about I'd worry about
a daughter more than it's time I thought
you were worried about them being catty
with each other that's why I thought
okay well no I thought you're worried
with with the double/double [ __ ]
periods Oh true oh yeah if you guys had
to choose you guys do boy boy girl boy
or girl girl girl girl girl boy and then
I'm done I want Oh girl boy boy boy all
girls cuz girls are gonna take care of
me and they'll stay they'll keep the
family together boys they just they just
leave I was afraid of having true I felt
like that would have me like wrapped
around the finger you know it's just
kind of like daddy I want to don't just
you know you know I mean like I think
they they know how to control like a
father figure a little bit my
opportunity father off soccer in the
face me too
I knew you're in the head yep for what I
think I want a daughter first cuz she's
gonna tie the family together and in the
Sun because if you get the boy first
they're gonna be a piece of [ __ ] where's
your theory coming from yeah I I made it
up okay yeah Norris backs and Joseph all
right yeah hey mines I had a bigger
sister and my dad wasn't around much so
I feel I was raised by women and I think
it was tight there we go I think in most
cases that explains the mannerisms what
mannerisms go ahead I thought I have
strong male mannerisms some say alpha I
would agree with that you have an older
sister do you think you would have liked
you like I would have had an older
brother he [ __ ] kicked my ass no
crazy I change like the dynamics in the
house so like did you feel like a little
bit more of like a tomboy growing up
having an older brother uh I don't know
cuz my sister's pretty tomboyish -
mm-hmm so I guess yeah she's not very
girly like she played softball and
basketball mm-hmm so I don't know but it
was like I had another mom I'd like to
mom cool
my mom had me at 17 so like I always
feel like I had like a really
young mom like growing up so I felt like
I kind of had like a little bit of a
best friend and my dad wasn't really
around actually it's all my that back
she got like deported a little later on
in my life oh [ __ ] so like when I was
growing up with my mom I felt like she
was like my best friend and she was
always opening up to me about like you
know you got to be chivalrous you gotta
open up doors you got to like do all
this [ __ ] and so like now when I do it
like when I've gone on like on dates in
the past and she didn't I open up doors
like there's certain girls are just like
wait what thank you teeth like I was
like yeah and I think it's just because
like I felt like that's what my mom
wanted to be treated like so I kind of
just took that in you're like let me get
the door for you and I'm gonna get you
pregnant without marrying you BAM that's
it well the traditional thing is the
shotgun wedding I think back then they
were like you would knock them up and
you'd have the shotgun my parents got
married yeah yeah there you go so what
is traditional that is true man got
married like 18th like a blind date I
mean they're still married but man is
that it's not a fun one before I saw
them standing next to each other at your
movie screen do that pretty successfully
wait they were there yeah that funny
story yeah I didn't know that and they
got a four-and-a-half-hour punking
traffic-jam going home and then they
fought and my dad was like if I do I
don't think I would have got sure sure
sure yeah yeah bill too late for my
opinion
so we get Steve I know it's too late
Steve uh can be proud of me now but you
weren't part of me then that's what I
say yeah you know let it go Steve hold
on to it I can't you know what you know
why cuz it drives me and I need it oh
yeah yeah yeah hold on to it then don't
let it go so your ultimate like reason
for success is to go in your face dad oh
yeah a good reason what if he doesn't
give a [ __ ] he's like that's what's
that's why it works okay because no
matter what I do he doesn't give much of
a [ __ ] top yourself yes endless
motivation that's right that's pretty
good hey dude that's what that's what's
gonna make the thinning three [ __ ]
he likes to channel his aggression into
heart I try I'm not all my aggression
into walls well he channels it into
Nikki - I channel it into heady it goes
into a dick and it goes into a vagina
you make a movie down [ __ ] you make a
movie I'm looking at you in the camera
you make a movie then [ __ ] you make a
movie are you talking to yourself is
yeah anyway so what do you have in the
works other than boys I mean just
continuing like the YouTube [ __ ] man
skids like gas gets a speed of skits
remember when we shut up I'll never
forget man we shot a how to get a asian
girl funny thing about that is is Gio is
a hundred percent [ __ ] the Mexican baby
no you're just an annoying we were
cracking up so [ __ ] hard though when
you cast it really back so so at that
time no one reviewed the revealed their
ethnicity was Joe Bart myself um so then
people just started assuming that I was
a mix of Asian mm-hm I'm like all right
whatever cool I got like accepted in
every single group it was a quite
beautiful and then you hit me up if I
wanted to be in that and I asked why I'm
like dude I can't do this that's fine he
goes but you're you're acting like
that's what actors do all the time Mel
Gibson's not Irish is he mm-hmm
listen nobody trailblaze like Tom Cruise
did in the beautiful movie The Last
Samurai yeah that's true he's not even
Japanese but he pretended he was
Japanese he's playing a white guy from
like the are you serious yeah I don't
think he was trying to watch he was a
like a captain in like the Civil War
area of time and then he moved to Japan
didn't have an Asian mom and dad I think
you're thinking bloodsport I could be
more Lionheart I think I'm thinking the
Lionheart anyway so you felt like yeah
it was torn I was really torn I didn't
want to do it imports like I just do it
it'd be a good opportunity you're acting
I was like anyone thought your agent in
the comment section everyone was just
sitting there fighting she said no she
shouldn't work that's me yeah I mean
after we file that's one of the reasons
why we didn't reveal is because people
just kept fighting about it it's still
fine ivory-billed it so much that I'm
Mexican and people are still like so
what part of good you know Asia is your
family from what stuff the new thing is
deals white that's the new thing stupid
I'm French with your last name or like
your middle name and people think you're
part French or some oh but you're
looking at friends John French people
can't have that name like I know a lot
of black people with that name there's
so many white Mexicans oh look at Eric
yes Leah Terry this guy [ __ ] love
chain restaurants you like [ __ ] tequila
that's very true
he likes to shitty is tequila known to
man what oh it's patron and it's
terrible stuff I never said that oh yeah
you don't have it on record
oh yeah prove it Tim's vlogs what about
the receipts oh yeah it's in the Tim's
vlogs you know you like patron to its
set and I heard you like chain
restaurants too that's what I'm all that
kind of [ __ ] to go to Chile do you know
what he wants
[Music]
[Music]